Was wissen Sie über den Toten?
Der Tote ...
Er verstarb in Biel.
Er war 32.
Es ist
ein aussergewöhnlicher Todesfall.
Deshalb war er
in der Gerichtsmedizin,
wo sie abklärten,
wie er ums Leben kam.
Melancholische Musik
Enver Fazliji war 20 Jahre alt,
als seine Grossmutter starb
und die Familie vergeblich nach
einem muslimischen Bestatter suchte.
Vermutlich hätten andere
das gleiche Problem, dachte er sich
und fragte seinen Vater, ob sie sich
selbstständig machen wollten.
Nach zähen Anfangsjahren
wickeln Fazliji Junior und Senior
mittlerweile rund 10 islamische
Beerdigungen pro Monat ab –
mehrheitlich
für albanische Landsleute.
Die rituellen Waschungen
finden auf dem Areal des Friedhofes
Zürich-Witikon statt –
nahe dem Flughafen, denn die meisten
Leichname werden nach Hause geflogen.
Die männlichen Toten wäscht er
zusammen mit seinem Vater.
Frauen dürfen dagegen
nur von Frauen gewaschen werden –
in solchen Fällen
kommt jeweils die Mutter mit.
Was haben Sie hier alles dabei?
Das sind Waschutensilien.
Das Leichentuch ist dabei,
Shampoo, Schwämme,
Schürzen für uns,
damit wir nicht nass werden.
Und natürlich die Gummistiefel.
2 Onkel und ein Cousin
des Verstorbenen sind gekommen –
die Eltern und die Geschwister sind
bereits nach Kosovo vorausgeflogen.
Die Zeit drängt:
Vom Tod bis zur Beisetzung dürfen
nicht mehr als 48 Std. vergehen.
Sie sprechen Albanisch.
Eigentlich sind die Angehörigen
meistens dabei,
denn das ist im Islam so.
Jeder Moslem sollte in seinem Leben
mind. 3 Leichen waschen.
Das ist so im Koran festgeschrieben.
Und es ist auch eine gute Tat,
das können Sie sich so vorstellen:
Er ist zwar verstorben,
doch seine Seele ist noch hier.
D.h., er hört alles, spürt alles,
kann aber nichts sagen.
Ein Verstorbener
schämt sich weniger,
wenn er von Angehörigen
gewaschen wird,
als wenn es Leute tun,
die ihn vorher nicht kannten.
Darum ist es immer gut,
wenn Angehörige dabei sind.
Schwermütige Musik
Er spricht Albanisch.
Naim war noch sehr klein,
als ich in die Schweiz gegangen bin.
Seine ersten Jahre
habe ich leider verpasst.
Erst als sein Vater ihn
mit 10 Jahren in die Schweiz holte,
haben wir uns öfter gesehen.
Mein Neffe war ein guter Mensch,
das kann ich sagen.
Man konnte zu ihm gehen,
wenn man etwas auf dem Herzen hatte.
Er war fröhlich. Immer fröhlich.
Wenn er zu Besuch kam,
also zu uns nach Hause,
brachte er einfach
eine gewisse Stimmung mit.
Wenn er da war,
dann lachten immer alle.
Es war einfach interessant.
Die ersten 3, 4 Aufträge
waren schon belastend.
Sie verfolgten mich auch nachts,
wenn ich schlafen ging.
Träumten Sie schlecht?
Ja. Das ist der Fehler:
Wir nahmen es mit nach Hause.
Man muss das klar trennen:
Berufliches und Privates.
Je mehr man das macht,
umso besser kann man damit umgehen.
Aber es nimmt einen
trotzdem jedes Mal mit.
Denn man denkt immer, morgen könnte
es mich treffen.
Oder ein Familienmitglied,
und dann ...
Haben Sie Angst, dass es jemanden
aus Ihrer Familie treffen könnte?
Das beschäftigt mich, ja.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich damit umgehen würde.
Würden Sie z.B. Ihren Vater waschen,
wenn er sterben würde?
Ja, wenn er mir vorher sagt,
dass er das will,
dann mache ich das.
Das ist für mich selbstverständlich,
dass ich das mache.
Wir werden nur damit
vor Gott treten,
bei der Auferstehung.
Moslems glauben an die Auferstehung.
Bei der Auferstehung
werden wir nur das tragen,
und dann wird entschieden,
wer Gutes und wer Böses getan hat,
wer ins Paradies
und wer in die Hölle kommt.
Von den 350'000 Moslems,
die hier leben,
gehen weniger als 5 %
in die Moschee.
Wenn wir Glück haben, gehen
vielleicht 20'000 in die Moschee -
die anderen
interessieren sich nicht gross.
Das sind sozusagen Kausalgläubige.
Die gehen nur in die Moschee,
oder eben auch in die Kirche,
bei Geburten, bei Hochzeiten,
und eben wenn jemand stirbt.
Dann ist es ihnen wichtig.
Religiöser Sprechgesang
Die letzte Reise kostet 3'000 Fr.
All inclusive –
egal, wohin es geht.
Laut Fazliji wollen keine 5 % ihre
letzte Ruhe in der Schweiz finden.
Obwohl mittlerweile diverse Friedhöfe
muslimische Grabfelder anbieten,
wird das Angebot noch kaum genutzt.
Wenn Sie einmal sterben,
möchten Sie auch ausgeflogen werden,
oder möchten Sie
in der Schweiz beerdigt werden?
Ich möchte eigentlich
hier beerdigt werden,
da ich hier aufgewachsen bin,
die Schule und alles hier machte.
Ich habe
Kollegen und Familie hier.
Wenn ich entscheiden könnte,
möchte ich hier beerdigt werden.
Das Leben führte sie in die Schweiz
und der Tod führt sie
zurück in ihre Heimat.
Das stimmt für die erste Generation,
die Zweite wird vermutlich
bleiben wollen – für immer.
Sanfte Klaviermusik
Das Presevo-Tal ist eine albanische
Enklave auf serbischem Gebiet,
ein paar Autominuten von
der kosovarischen Grenze entfernt.
Hier wartete Enver Fazliji
seine ersten 6 Jahre darauf,
dass ihm das Leben
eine Perspektive eröffnen würde –
seine Onkel und Cousins
warten immer noch.
In den Wintermonaten liegt die
Arbeitslosigkeit hier nahe bei 100 %.
Im Sommer kommen die Verwandten,
die es ins Ausland geschafft haben,
und bringen ein wenig Arbeit,
Zuversicht und Geschichten,
die davon erzählen,
wie fremd man sich geworden ist.
Man ist eigentlich ein Ausländer
für die Menschen hier.
Und die Schweizer
sehen einen auch als Ausländer.
Irgendwie gehört man nirgends ...
... so richtig dazu.
Ja.
Und was für ein Gefühl ist das?
Ich weiss es nicht,
es ist einfach, ja ...
Da fühlt man sich wieder so einsam.
Ohne Zugehörigkeit.
So viele Leute um sich herum,
und doch fühlt man sich einsam.
Man gehört
eben doch nicht 100 % dazu.
Man ist ja nicht hier,
man leidet ja nicht mit
an dieser Armut,
die die Menschen hier haben,
oder an dieser Perspektivlosigkeit.
Sanfte Klaviermusik
Das Leben gab Enver Fazliji
eine Chance –
und er gab dem Leben
sein Talent und seinen Fleiss.
Er baute
ein Bestattungsunternehmen auf
und schuftete gleichzeitig 80 %
als Sachbearbeiter – heute noch 60 %.
Er arbeitet und arbeitet,
als ob ihm die Armut
dicht auf den Fersen bliebe.
Mit 28 Jahren
hat er es bereits weit gebracht.
So weit, dass die Sicht auf
die Heimat allmählich verschwimmt.
Ihr Ziel wäre schon,
irgendwann Millionär zu werden, oder?
Millionär nicht, aber dass ich mir
keine Sorgen um Geld machen muss.
Und dass ich irgendwann
in ein anderes Land ziehen kann,
wo man nicht
so viel Stress ausgesetzt ist,
oder so viele Sorgen hat,
sondern einfach ...
Wo würden Sie dann hinziehen?
Z.B. hierher.
Hierher zurück?
Zum Beispiel.
Würde es Ihnen hier nicht langweilig?
Lieber Langeweile
als zu viel Stress.
Sie würden gar nicht mehr
richtig dazugehören?
Sie wären dann immer der Schweizer?
Ja, da müsste man eben mal schauen,
wie das wäre.
Denn ich habe ja noch viel
mit Jugendlichen zu tun,
und hier ist die Jugend
noch nicht so ...
kaputt wie in der Schweiz,
sagen wir es mal so.
In den Ausgang gehen, z.B.,
das kennen sie nicht.
Sie leben eigentlich alle
in bescheidenen Verhältnissen.
Ist die Jugend in der Schweiz
aus Ihrer Sicht kaputt?
Aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Denn diese Leute gehen
jedes Wochenende in den Ausgang -
Alkohol, Drogen -
Sie hören nicht mehr
auf ihre Eltern.
Das kann so nicht sein.
Sie haben einfach
den Respekt vor ihren Eltern,
vor alten Leuten verloren.
Idealisieren Sie das Leben hier
nicht ein bisschen?
Das könnte sein, ja.
Das könnte sein.
Kämen Sie zurück, sähen Sie,
dass die Wirklichkeit
nicht Ihren Vorstellungen entspricht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so.
Ich sage bloss,
dass es eine Möglichkeit ist.
Ich könnte
zurück in mein Heimatland kommen.
Alle anderen hätten freilich gerne
die umgekehrte Option:
Bloss weg von hier.
In der Schweiz
hat man garantiert einen Lohn.
Sozialversicherungsleistungen,
den Staat, Sicherheit.
Man hat alles.
Und hier ...
Ja, aber auch Stress, oder?
Sie sprechen Albanisch.
Lieber Stress und dafür Geld haben,
als gestresst zu sein,
weil man nichts zu Essen hat.
Aber die,
die schon in der Schweiz waren,
waren sie dort glücklich?
Er fragt sie auf Albanisch.
Er sagt, er war glücklicher.
Im Kanton Solothurn
hat sich Fazliji letztes Jahr
ein schönes Haus gekauft.
Jenes, in dem er aufgewachsen ist,
steht seit Jahren leer.
Hier wohnen nur noch die Erinnerungen
an eine Zeit, in der sein Leben
noch aus dem trügerischen Schein zu
versäumender Möglichkeiten bestand.
Entweder dort oder hier
war das Wohnzimmer.
Da hat man einfach
auf den Boden so ...
... Schaumstoff-Dinger hingestellt.
Dann sass man einfach hin.
Da war noch ein Teppich.
Hier kam ich zur Welt.
In diesem Zimmer.
Meine Grossmutter war die Hebamme.
Anfang der 90er-Jahre kamen er
und seine 2 Brüder in die Schweiz.
Es musste aufwärts gehen,
das war klar.
Wurden Sie denn früher
nie als Jugo bezeichnet?
Doch, ganz am Anfang schon,
als ich klein war.
Doch ich merkte,
Leute reagieren ganz anders -
je mehr Erfolg du hast ...
... desto lieber sind sie
mit dir zusammen,
oder desto lieber
werden sie mit dir gesehen,
sie reden lieber mit dir.
Man wird ganz anders behandelt,
als wenn man arm ist.
Oder keine Schulbildung hat.
Man integriert sich also
durch den Erfolg.
Das ist so.
Also, in meinem Fall war es so.
Man kann sich in der Schweiz
nur durch Erfolg integrieren.
Sanfte Klaviermusik
Es ist eine Ironie des Lebens,
dass dieser Erfolg nur möglich wurde,
weil er sich seiner grössten Angst
aus Kindertagen stellte:
der Angst vor Toten.
Er überwand diese Angst
und konnte eine Nische besetzen.
Neben ihm gibt es nur noch einen
weiteren muslimischen Bestatter
in der Schweiz.
Mittlerweile ist der Tod
zu einem Vertrauten geworden.
Die Heimat zu besuchen, bedeutet
für Fazliji heute immer auch,
das Familiengrab zu besuchen.
Es kommen einfach Erinnerungen
an meinen Grossvater hoch -
wie es war, als er
und meine Grossmutter noch lebten.
Das ist es. Und:
Es wäre doch schön,
wenn man beerdigt wird,
neben ihnen zu liegen.
Ich selber würde das nicht spüren,
aber ...
... die anderen Leute,
meine Angehörigen.
Für sie ist es gut,
wenn alle nebeneinander liegen,
wenn sie mich besuchen können.
In unserer Tradition ist es wichtig,
dass man die Toten besuchen geht
und ihnen ein Gebet spricht.
Das ist für sie vielleicht
hilfreich, wenn ich dann mal sterbe.
Schwermütige Musik
Die letzte Reise
des verstorbenen Naim Kerqeli
geht ihrem Ende entgegen,
dem Elternhaus
in der kosovarischen Stadt Gjilan –
eine Autostunde
von Pristina entfernt.
Hier verbrachte er
seine ersten 10 Geburtstage –
seinen 32. verbrachte er in Biel –
es war zugleich sein Todestag.
Die Familie nimmt Abschied
von einem Sohn, einem Ehemann,
einem Bruder, einem Vater,
einem Neffen und einem Cousin –
das alles sei Naim Kerqeli
im Leben gewesen, sagt seine Familie,
bis er an einem Herzinfarkt
gestorben ist.
Schwermütige Flötenmusik
Ein jeder wird einmal
den Tod erleiden, sagt der Koran.
Das Kommen und das Gehen folgen einem
göttlichen Plan, lehrt der Islam.
Wenn eine Frau schwanger ist,
kommt im 3. Monat
ein Engel zu ihr -
wenn sie also
das Baby im Bauch trägt.
Der Engel bringt 3 Sachen mit.
Das Erste ist das Leben, die Seele,
damit das Kind
dann überhaupt anfängt zu atmen
und damit sein Herz schlägt.
Das Zweite ist sein Schicksal,
was das Kind alles erreichen wird,
welche Träume ihm erfüllt werden.
Und das Dritte ist der Todestag,
wann diese Person sterben wird.
Das ist schon alles
von Gott festgelegt und vorgegeben.
D.h. also, das vorbestimmt ist,
wann Gott jemanden zu sich holt.
Der Verstorbene
kommt zu Gott zurück,
deshalb sollte man
sich eigentlich freuen.
So, wie man sich über eine Geburt
freut, sollte man sich auch freuen,
wenn jemand stirbt
und zum Schöpfer zurückkehrt.
Sie sprechen Albanisch.
Ich wollte meinen Sohn
hier beerdigen,
weil das unsere Heimat ist.
Wir wollen alle hier begraben sein.
Ich will auch hierher zurückkommen,
wenn ich gestorben bin.
Unser Sohn war ein guter Sohn.
Es gibt keinen besseren
auf der Welt.
Ich werde
für meine Kinder weiterleben.
Ohne den Mann, mit dem ich
11 Jahre lang verheiratet war.
An einem Valentinstag
habe ich mich für ihn entschieden
und an einem Valentinstag
muss ich ihn nun begraben.
Gibt es etwas Traurigeres?
Neben den Angehörigen
begleiten auch Engel
den Körper des Verstorbenen
zur Moschee, glauben die Muslime.
Der Todesengel Izra'il
führt seine Seele derweil
zu einem Zwischengericht im Himmel.
Hat der Mensch ein Gott
wohlgefälliges Leben geführt,
wird ihm mitgeteilt, dass ihm
alle seine Sünden vergeben sind.
Haben der Glaube
und die Taten des Verstorbenen
vor Gott keinen Bestand,
wird die Seele zum Versammlungsort
der Verdammten gebracht.
Allahu Akbar.
Der Prediger spricht ein Gebet.
Später führt der Todesengel Izra'il
die Seele zurück ins Grab,
wo sie
in einer Art dämmrigen Schlaf wartet
bis zur Auferstehung
am Tag des Jüngsten Gerichts.
Darum ist die ewige Totenruhe
so wichtig für die Muslime.
Da sind die Emotionen
natürlich noch geladener,
wenn die verstorbene Person
ins Heimatland kommt
und man das alles sieht.
Also, ich war heute auch nahe dran,
eigentlich ...
... zu weinen, sozusagen.
Ehrlich?
Ja.
V.a. wegen dem Interview
mit seiner Frau, wegen all dem.
Ja, das ging mir recht nahe.
Das ist eben der Zusammenhalt,
der mir gefällt.
Als meine Grossmutter starb,
kamen auch sehr viele Leute vom Dorf
und brachten Essen und Trinken mit.
Und sie halfen uns,
sie packten mit an.
Es kamen sehr viele Leute
und kondolierten.
Das ist es, was ich an dieser Kultur
extrem positiv finde.
Schwermütige Flötenmusik
Von hier ist Naim Kerqeli gekommen,
hierher kehrt er nun zurück.
Und Enver Fazliji ist sich plötzlich
nicht mehr so sicher,
ob er wirklich
in der Schweiz begraben werden will.
Nachdem ich das
jetzt gesehen habe ...
... muss ich mir das wirklich
nochmals überlegen.
Ich denke, wenn man mich jetzt
nochmals fragen würde,
würde ich hier
begraben werden wollen.
Wegen den Emotionen,
der ganzen Anteilnahme der Menschen.
In der Schweiz
kommt das nie zustande.
In der Schweiz kommt fast niemand.
Fast niemand.
Jetzt würde ich eigentlich sagen:
hier.
Und so endet diese Geschichte
mit der Erkenntnis,
dass wir unseren Tod so verbringen,
wie wir unser Leben verbracht haben:
Die einen für die anderen
und die anderen für sich.